ever heard a rumor about yourself and
actually wanted to hear more like damn
what did I do next Selena Gomez pokes
fun at her life in the spotlight I'm
very honest though in general the
actress sharing this Tick Tock joking
about the gossip report swirling about
her ever heard a rumor about yourself
and actually wanted to hear more like
damn what did I do next sales caption to
everyone from me I think it's nice to
have a little bit something to myself as
for what she's referencing well it could
be the recent headlines about cell's
relationship status
yeah that's the singer shooting her shot
at a soccer game making it clear she's
single and ready to mingle I'm just a
little high maintenance
but I'll love you so much and if cell's
not referencing her dating life it could
be about the reports of her alleged
former Feud with Haley Bieber coming to
surface again oh my goodness almost
three months after Selena and Haley
who's married to her ex Justin Bieber
squashed Feud rumors the model shared
this message on Monday addressing
hateful commentary and urged her fans to
stop leaving mean or rude comments on
her behalf Haley simply saying please be
nice or don't say anything and while she
doesn't mention cell by name many fans
believe it was a response to Selena's
latest post being filled with cruel
comments on social media it's as much as
it's a blessing and it's fun it it can
really tear people down and I always
hope that the people I'm involved with
or support me can just kind of spread
love within that as for Selena's recent
social media posts she's just keeping
things real just a quick question to
anyone who's over 30
supposed to be doing and while she's not
on the clock app it looks like she's
working on new music you know I'm ready
to go to the next level with him Selena
teased next to pics of herself in a
studio don't worry guys it's coming even
from Paris
come and get it
[Music]